JENNY MURPHY: Hi there
everybody.
Welcome to the first on-air
edition of the Google+
Platform Office Hours.
So before we dig into stuff,
I'm going to do a quick
introduction and we're
all going to say hi.
I'm Jenny Murphy.
I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer here.
I'm at the Googleplex
in Mountain View.
And something cool I guess,
I've been building--
I've been building a lot of
cool stuff on the Google+
Platform as you might expect,
because I do it every day.
But I can't talk about some of
the stuff I'm working on.
But if you check my personal
blog, you will find a lot of
stuff I've been hacking at
recently, including a little
comments widget that you can
use to learn to play with
comments in your blog.
JONATHAN BARRY: And I'm
Jonathan Barry.
I'm a Developer Advocate
on Google+.
I work on hangouts specifically
at Googleplex,
because I'm right
next to Jenny.
That's pretty obvious.
But something cool that I've
been working on, almost ready
to release, so you get to hear
it first. We've got the Jazz
client for our JavaScript
API--
sorry--
our layer APIs working
inside of a hangout.
So that means things like
blogger, moderator, latitude--
anything that's in our
new API stack--
it can be found at
code.google.com/api/explorer--
is now available to hangout.
It's pretty exciting.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
It's the first I've heard
about it too.
All right, so let's
go left to right.
So [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So I'm [? Gavin ?]
from Austria.
So I've been doing lots of stuff
with the Google APIs.
Recently, the most recent thing
is hangout apps I've
been doing this hangout disco,
which is a [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
rendered 3D room that you have
little entries for every
participant, which can walk
around and they can wave and
turn their heads,
which I can't.
The most popular thing I've
been doing is on my Plus
Statistics tool, which reads all
of your public posts which
the API will return.
And then it will calculate all
kinds of statistics for the--
counts how many pictures
you've posted, how many
comments you've got, how many
Plus Ones you've got.
So it does all kinds of fun
stuff, really, and people
really seem to like numbers.
So got to have them.
And I also included
some charts.
We have the charts API, which
is really good to play with.
Yup, that's about it.
JENNY MURPHY: How
about Fraser.
You're next.
FRASER CAIN: All right.
So my name is Fraser Cain, and
I'm the publisher of "Universe
Today." And we've been
using Google+ for
all kinds of things.
So let's see, I'm located on
Vancouver Island in Canada.
So we record the astronomy
podcast now.
We do it as a live Google+
hangout so people can watch.
And then at the end of the
recording of the show, we
invite everyone in and they
can sort of join in and
hangout, and that's publicly
available to lots of people.
We've actually been doing
that for about four
or five months now.
We've had it on the air for
the last probably month.
We do a weekly space roundup
with a whole bunch of space
science journalists.
So from MSNBC and Discovery
and Discover.
Phil Plait from "Bad Astronomy."
And my co-host
Pamela Gay.
And so once a week we kind
of do a roundup.
It's almost like a CNN
style news roundup.
It's pretty cool.
We've actually been hacking
the hangouts quite a bit.
So what we do is we have a
separate website where we're
able to pull in the embed code
for the actual stream, and so
it sort of makes it a
permanent location.
You can always go and
check it out.
We're making all that code
freely available.
We've actually integrated
Twitter and Google+ comments
into this page at
the same time.
So you can kind of see all
of the comments that are
happening, but you do have to
come back to Google+ to
actually comment on it.
We've been creating a
infrastructure of building
role playing games-- playing
role playing
games through Google+.
So using the Google Apps, you
can actually go and roll dice
within the app itself, and the
results the die role are shown
to everybody, so it's
not cheating.
We've actually also built an
extension that does that, so
everyone who's going to be
playing the game, it actually
modifies their interface and
you can roll dice and the
results are shown
to everybody.
And the latest iteration
with the apps right
now is we're actually--
my partner on this, Charles
Jaimet, has built-- you
actually can embed a game board
into the hangout with
the apps, and you can actually
move pieces around and see
people's positions.
So we're still trying to figure
it out, but it's pretty
cool technology.
So yeah, we doing
tons of stuff.
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
All right, Allen, you're next.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Hi there.
I'm Allen Firstenberg
from New York.
Mostly I've been focusing on the
hangout plus API, and with
a wide variety of stuff.
So I've been doing some games,
some parlor games.
The last round of things that
I've been working on has been
some apps to work with
preschool children.
So the preschool children and
their parents can do something
interactive together through
a hangout or
through an Android app.
So I've been trying to create
apps that cross that line,
work on multiple platforms. And
I'm very much targeting
the hangout API as one of
my primary platforms.
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
And finally, last but
not least, Martin.
MARTIN: OK.
Hi.
I'm Martin.
I'm a computer science
student from Germany.
And I've been working with
Google+ API ever since the
first day it went public.
So I do a lot of experiments
with it.
Also like [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
commenting engine
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Most recently, I'm working on
various Chrome extensions that
enhance your Google+
experience.
So I started a tool which
you can bookmark
posts directly on Google+.
And I'm also part of the team
that's working on the my
hangouts extension.
So yeah, if you're interested
in trying any one of them,
check out my profile.
You'll find all the
things in there.
JONATHAN BARRY: And actually,
anybody watching this video
afterwards, we'll provide all
the links for all the cool
demos that people
talked about.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
Get out.
So without further adieu, I'm
going to dive into that live
coding I promised, and
we'll actually be--
we're going to create a tool
that will be relevant for this
hangout itself.
So I'm going to fire up screen
sharing and show you what I'm
talking about.
You can see the hall of
mirrors just briefly.
And here we go.
So the problem I'm trying to
address, this little hack, is
we have our hangouts on air.
And we were fielding
questions, if
any of you were watching.
Just reply a comment on the
thread, and we're going to be
responding to those questions
later on in the hangout.
And this works really well,
except after a little while
the auto updating of this page
turns off, and I'm going to
have to reload it every
few minutes to
see the latest comments.
And while you're doing all the
other stuff and hangouts on
there, that can be a little
bit distracting.
So I'm going to use the comments
API to write a little
tool that pulls the
API and sucks
down the latest comments.
So let me show a little
mock-up of what I'm
envisioning.
So there's a little
tool you go to.
You pop in your activity ID for
your favorite activity.
And I've already gone and
grabbed the activity for this
post. Hit a button--
oops.
Actually, not up and
working yet.
Initial.
We show the mock-up, you pop in
the ID and you hit submit.
And what it does is it
posts the comments--
it fetches the comments and
it inserts them into
the page at the top.
As time passes, it fetches the
new comments, and keeps
updating them as time passes, so
that we can just look back
here and see the latest
activity.
So back to the working
version.
Let's take a look at the code
that this mock-up uses before
we dive into the JavaScript
Client Library and APIs.
So here's the code for
that little mock-up.
We have some HTML elements,
which is where
the stuff gets inserted.
Nothing too exciting here.
We have the definition list
where the comments actually
end up getting pushed.
We have that forum with the
little button that you saw
called a JavaScript method
right now, and some text.
This JavaScript method is right
up above, and you can
see it's pretty simple
right now.
All it does is call another
method and passes in a chunk
of JavaScript objects, which is
the little comments you saw
showing up right here.
And the structure looks like
something we may get back from
an API, but it's just
a format of what a
comment might look like.
And it's calling the
method down below.
And this method just does
a bunch of little HTML
manipulations.
It creates some elements.
It copies some data into them.
Cleans up some other stuff,
strips some tags out, and then
inserts it into that definition
list in the HTML.
So this is our starting point.
We have a little chunk of
locally running JavaScript to
insert some data.
So how do we go from here to
something that's actually
working and pulling down the
comments for our activity?
We could hit the reference docs
and try and figure out
all the methods we need to call,
and how the JavaScript
Client Library works.
But I prefer to work from
examples whenever I can.
So digging around--
sorry about that.
Make it a little
more readable.
So I noticed there was this
really cool blog post. It was
published when we released
the alpha version of the
JavaScript Client Library.
And scrolling down here, we can
see there's a really neat,
simple, like 50-line example
showing you how to use the
JavaScript Client Library
to search some Google+
activities.
So let's come and paste that
into our own file and see what
it looks like when it runs.
So here's the exact same code
from the blog post,
just paste it in.
And I'm going to pull it up in
my browser, reload, and we can
see it running.
So what it looks like it's
doing is it's searching
Google+ for Google+.
And taking a page of activities
that it finds and
just telling us a little
bit about them.
And if we go back to the code,
we can totally see this makes
a lot of sense.
Because we look at the document,
we only see one HTML
element, which is where it's
inserting, apparently
inserting all the activities
it finds.
We see that it's sourcing the
JavaScript Client Library.
And it's using an onload hook
to call an initialization
function, which is the only
other function in this file.
And we can see what this
function does.
It bootstraps the JavaScript
Client Library.
It loads it, and sets it up
to use the Google+ APIs.
Then it sets up a query.
It's doing one query.
It's searching for activities.
We can see the query, Google+,
which correlates to what we
saw on the screen, and it's
specifying an order.
Then upon execution, it's taking
the response and doing
some HTML manipulations to
insert the stuff into that
content below.
See the little content
right there.
This is really close to what
we're trying to build with our
little comments sucker
downer feature.
In fact, you can probably just
get started by copying the
stuff we see here.
So let's start with that.
First, we need the JavaScript
Client Library before we can
do anything else, so we'll
copy that into our code.
We'll go up here.
There's one difference between
the example from the blog
post, and what we're working
on now, is the example from
the blog post uses an
initialization function, or
rather it's calling it
initialization function once
the JavaScript Client
Library loads.
We're using a button, so we
don't really need to do that.
So we can remove that.
And we're just sourcing the
JavaScript Client Library.
Then let's grab this whole
initialization function and
just start from there.
So punch in the net, and let's
replace our insert a comment
function like that.
So now we have taken the example
from the blog post,
pasted it into our
little tool, and
let's see what happened.
We haven't actually changed
anything yet.
But let's see what happens
when we run it.
So we load our local file, and
we can see that it's working.
We haven't broken the example.
It's going, it's running a
search, and it's inserting it
into our page, which means we've
actually accomplished a
surprising amount for just
having pasted a little code.
We've managed to source the
JavaScript Client Library,
which means it's available for
us to use, and we've managed
to run a query from our tool,
which means we're
really close actually.
But it's the wrong query, and
we're doing the wrong thing
with the data.
So let's tackle these problems
one at a time.
First let's figure out what the
correct query to run is
and let's run it.
So we can see here in
our code that we're
running activity search.
We could hit the reference
docs and figure out which
method we should probably run,
but I like hands-on tools.
So I'm going to go to the API
explorer, which a lot of
people have probably seen.
It's one of my favorite
little tools.
And it shows us all the
available Google+ APIs, what
we can do with them.
Right now it's running
activity search
with the query Google+.
And we can see that the text
here corresponds to the code.
So knowing that, it's probably
a good guess that we can just
take other methods and
run them and use the
parameters we see here.
So let's try a comments dot
list. But a comments dot list
doesn't take a query, it
takes an activity ID.
So we'll take an activity ID.
And just to save us the trouble
of paging through
results, let's set a max result
to the maximum size,
which is 100.
Also, our activity
ID isn't Google+.
It's actually a long string,
which I fetched earlier on.
This is the activity ID of the
Google+ post that you're
looking at right now if you're
watching the hangout on air.
JONATHAN BARRY: Now, of course,
you could have gotten
that activity ID from
a search, right?
JENNY MURPHY: I could have
gotten it from a search, or
more easily I could have gotten
it from an activities
list, because activities list
is only going to show my
activities.
So I can show you
that right now.
So that's my profile ID, and
we can actually see--
there's a trailing space.
Here we go.
We can actually see this
activity ID in relative
activities responded from
the API explorer.
But going back to the
demo, let's see
what this looks like.
So we load our little page.
We run it.
And we see a whole bunch
of undefineds.
This means we've probably
successfully executed the
query against the comments list
endpoint, which is half
of the problems we're
trying to deal with.
We just haven't-- we're not
responding to it correctly,
we're not dealing
with it right.
But that's pretty easy.
All we need to do is invoke
our little insert a new
comment method on the results
from that query.
So let's take a look and
try and do that.
Let's see what happens.
So let's trim down the stuff we
have up here a little bit.
We still need to find a place
where we're going to be
inserting our comments, although
the class name is a
little different, or the
ID will be different.
And we have favorite activity
comments instead of content.
So that's going to go insert
at the bottom of the page
instead of up at the top.
And then we're going to have to
loop through the results,
just like on the blog
post example I did.
Except we're going to handle
them a little differently.
Rather than just doing all the
HTML manipulations here, we're
going to offload into
that method.
And we're going to do it for
each one of the response dot
items. And it looks
like we might have
something that works.
But how can we be sure that the
response, the structure of
the response matches what our
insert new comments method
expects with that
comment.actor.image.url and
comment.actor, and
all that stuff.
Since we're doing it with the
JavaScript client, we can do
this pretty easily.
We can use your favorite web
browser debugging tools, like
Firebug or Chrome dev tools
to figure this out.
So let's just make sure that
everything lines up.
So we're going to save
it, reload our page,
fire up the dev tools.
Go over to the script tab.
Sorry the font's tiny.
I actually can't make
this bigger.
But just run the query.
And take a look at
what comes out.
So hopefully this is visible.
We can see there is an array
of 25 items coming out.
And each one of these items just
happens to have the same
structure as that JSON that we
were passing into that insert
a new comment method.
As an actor with a display name,
and an image, and it has
an object with the content,
which is very convenient,
because that means
we don't have to
change any of that code.
We can just pass these responses
in straightaway.
So let's see it in action.
So we'll hit the play button,
let it keep running.
Remove the break point and
let it finish running.
We can see comments up here.
But there's one kind of
a downside right now.
If I keep hitting this button
and keep running the query,
it's going to keep inserting
comments and our page is going
to get longer and longer.
Because the rest of the
API is stateless.
It doesn't know what comments
we've already fetched.
We're going to have to be
responsible on the client side
for making sure that we only
deal with the comments we have
received once.
So we only insert them into
the web page once.
This is pretty easy.
We can use a little local index
for the good stuff, a
little hash.
So let's add this
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So I'm going to create a little
hash in the global name
space, because I guess I'm a
little sloppy like that.
And then all we need to do is
conditionally insert the
comment if we've never
seen it before.
So what we're going to index is
by the ID of the comment.
So if we've never seen the
comment before, then we will
insert it, and then mark it as
something that we've not seen.
So reloading our app.
We can see that it's not loading
all the comments.
JONATHAN BARRY: Google hangouts
using live debugging.
JENNY MURPHY: So let's jump
ahead to one that's working.
So we can see it actually
doesn't debug it.
I'll just show you what the
final outcome looks like.
MALE SPEAKER: I think
you missed the--
FRASER CAIN: Were you looping
through your reading?
JENNY MURPHY: I am looping
through the reading response.
But rather than spend
time debugging--
MALE SPEAKER:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
items. Items record I. In the
if statement because you--
JENNY MURPHY: Oh, right, right.
Thank you.
Yeah, this is the peril
of live debugging.
JONATHAN BARRY: The joy
JENNY MURPHY: The joy
of live debugging.
So we can actually see
it in action now.
I've kind of jumped ahead for
the sake of time diversion,
but it has a couple of
other tweaks too.
It does the same looping.
It conditionally selects
the right comments.
And it also keeps running that
query over and over again,
just using a set interval.
And that's it.
This is how easy it is to write
a little tool using the
comments API.
I'm going to switch back.
Stop my screens.
Hey there everyone again.
Sorry, some technical
difficulties.
I actually hit the close button
for the hangout instead
of the close button for
screen sharing.
So pardon the discontinuity,
but luckily the demo was
wrapping up anyway.
So how about we field
some questions?
So before I dive into questions,
does anyone who's
in the hangout have any
comments about--
or anything?
Comments or questions
before we dive into
the stream of questions?
FRASER CAIN: When could you make
that available in a more
official capacity, because
that would be very cool?
JENNY MURPHY: The little comment
streamer downer?
FRASER CAIN: Uh-huh.
JENNY MURPHY: Well there is one
limitation is that it's
currently pulling down the
comments in the order that
they were made.
So once the posts hit the 100
comments, you have to start
paging through the records.
Fortunately, we're adding an
enhancement really soon, like
some time in the next couple
days, where we're going to
allow you to reverse the order
of the comments you request.
So you'll get the newest
comments first, so that you
can pull without paging through
over and over and over
again, and burning through
all your quota.
FRASER CAIN: Oh, burning
through your quota.
Right.
JENNY MURPHY: And that will
make this much more
performant, much more
quota efficient, and
make it more feasible.
So once that's available, I'll
be releasing the code for it.
FRASER CAIN: And then
theoretically someone could
create an extension to
incorporate that into a
hangout itself.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Actually, you could probably
make it a hangout app, which
displays the comments for the
currently running hangout.
That shouldn't be a problem.
FRASER CAIN: Well, except that
it's pretty hard to start up a
hangout app for most people.
That it would probably
be easier--
MALE SPEAKER: [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
FRASER CAIN: --in the short
term to just create an
extension for Chrome that--
and then you would feed in the
activity ID, and then it would
start to show up the comments
somewhere on the interface of
the hangout itself.
That would be really helpful.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah.
It's one of the cool parts about
the JavaScript Client
Library is because it's
JavaScript you can put it in a
lot of places.
You can put it in the hangouts,
as Jonathan just
described you can now do.
You can put it in the
Chrome extension--
Almost, very soon.
And actually, we could just
throw that into a blog post
somewhere as long as it's
somewhere we can run
JavaScript.
And then anyone could come and
hit a button and say keep a
feed of my most recent
activities posts.
So that may be the
first version
that appears somewhere.
FRASER CAIN: I don't know if
you've noticed that after
every sort of hangout on air
live, everyone wants to know
how they can make
a full screen,
like within the first--
JONATHAN BARRY: Yup,
I saw that.
FRASER CAIN: --three comments.
So if anyone doesn't know,
there's a pretty cool
extension called Better Hangouts
On Air that you can
install that gives you little
buttons down at the bottom of
any hangout that you're watching
that lets you full
screen it, maximize the window,
embed it into another
website, that kind of thing.
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
Yeah, it's really cool to see
all the Chrome extensions that
have really made things
a lot better.
So I'm going to start fielding
some of the questions using
that same little widget I just
showed you guys to the right.
Anna is going first
in, first out.
So [? Holly Cronus ?]
asked a question.
Thanks for the hangout.
What is the status of releasing
a Circles API?
That's a great question.
The status really
hasn't changed.
It's something we know
it would really
cool to make available.
But it's something that's
in the future.
So unfortunately, as we often
say, we can't really say a lot
about the feature, because
things are always kind of
changing, and we want to make
sure that if we promise you
something that it's really
going to come out.
So let's hit the
next question.
Someone asked about hangout
to full screen.
Fraser already mentioned
there's a cool Chrome
extension for that.
So it was a question
like that.
And someone's mentioning
they cannot see the
text from the video.
Sorry about that.
I'll try and make it a little
bit bigger next time.
I have one with 20 point,
but it's apparently
not quite big enough.
FRASER CAIN: It looks very good
in the hangout itself.
So all of us could see it
quite well I think.
JENNY MURPHY: All but the
hangout on air is much smaller
on the window.
FRASER CAIN: Yeah.
So we see it--
the people who are in hangout,
we see it at full screen
resolution, 720.
We can see lots of subtle
details and great sound.
But the one that's published
live on air is I think 360p,
maybe 480, and the sound
quality's reduced as well.
So it's pretty hard to make
us visible on air side.
So just be aware of that when
you're trying to communicate
that kind of stuff.
You've got to really
oversize it.
JENNY MURPHY: Thanks, Fraser.
Well we'll set the width to 40
characters wide next time, and
really make it big.
That'll definitely be fun.
FRASER CAIN: Or make the thing
that shows up on the live side
higher definition.
JENNY MURPHY: That is definitely
another solution
that we can definitely
lobby for.
I definitely see the
benefit of it.
FRASER CAIN: Now you're
in our world.
JENNY MURPHY: True that.
Exactly.
So a lot of questions
about the extension
of the screen size.
JONATHAN BARRY: While Jenny's
going through the comments.
Anybody who is in the actual
hangout that you guys joined a
few minutes ago.
First of all, why don't
you do a proper intro.
Everybody's saying what they've
done on Google+, a
little bit about themselves,
and where they are.
ABRAHAM WILLIAMS: So I'm Abraham
Williams. I am mostly
a JavaScript developer at InboxQ
here in San Francisco.
And I built a Search+
for Google+.
It essentially does instant
search in the Chrome Omnibox.
And also, I've been working on
a HTML5 RTS game that I hope
to eventually get into
the games platform.
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
So still feeding up
to the comments.
FRASER CAIN: Abraham, did you
see that somebody had created
Command and Conquer in HTML5?
ABRAHAM WILLIAMS:
I noticed that.
I haven't had time to
look at it yet.
But it's definitely on
my list to look at.
JONATHAN BARRY: So it's funny
how [UNINTELLIGIBLE] shared
that link last week, and they
took down their servers.
So they're still having some
issues with rendering not the
HTML5 piece because that
works offline.
The actual static file
serving is down.
Yeah, it's pretty cool.
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
So I've managed to find another
question in the stream.
What editor am I using?
Not really about the Google+
platform, but
I'm happy to answer.
I'm using IntelliJ.
I'm a big fan of the JetBrains
IDEA products.
I would probably be using
WebStorm, but
IntelliJ was there.
When I'm not using IntelliJ,
I'm in Camp [? BI ?].
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: You also
had a long question--
where'd it go--
a long question from Steven
[? Ancliff ?].
There was a two-part question.
The first was asking about when
we're going to be able to
write Google+ using the API.
And the second was asking some
questions regarding Python.
JENNY MURPHY: Ah, let me
bring that one up.
JONATHAN BARRY: I think Jenny
touched a little bit about the
writing for API answering
the circle question.
No ETA.
For anybody's who's watched our
Office Hours before, we
just don't have answers
for that.
I don't want to be
a broken record.
But regarding the Python one.
JENNY MURPHY: So the other half
of this question, which I
missed on the first half, is
will we be covering Python
examples in this hangout?
I recently started learning
Python via Google Python class
and would love to see some
examples in this language.
So the short answer is not in
this specific hangout, but we
can definitely do it
in future sessions.
So if you have any specific
things you would like to see
us do with the Python Client
Library, because it's a pretty
cool client library
too, let us know.
Otherwise I'll make something
up, and we'll do this in a
future hangout.
Maybe next week, maybe
the week after.
But definitely.
So if people have any languages
or technologies they
want to see us using,
please let us know.
Very happy to take
your suggestions.
There's another question
from Abdula.
Are there any plans to provide
hangout APIs with functions to
create hangouts for specified
Google accounts or circles?
I mean the ability to
create hangouts
from external portals.
So it sounds like you're looking
for like a button or
badge or something that you can
embed in an external site.
And when people click on it,
it creates a hangout.
Which is a really cool idea.
It's kind of the idea of
hangouts everywhere.
But this isn't something
we have right now.
And as a result, it's
not something I
can really talk about.
I can't really make conjecture
about what we're really--
JONATHAN BARRY: We've heard
that request before from
people who run plus pages, and
people who are doing things
like last Saturday there was
an artist who did body
painting and a hangout on
a third-party site.
So it makes sense.
And we've definitely conveyed
that the team to look into
trying to go somewhere.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, because
we think it's really cool.
JONATHAN BARRY: No promises.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah.
We like pushing for
cool things.
So next question.
So Daniel asks about page
analytics on pages and stream
of posts related to--
people have mentioned that page
and page and control,
whatever is shown.
So he's asking about analytics
for Google+
pages it sounds like.
Again, cool idea.
I think it sounds really cool.
And this is more kind
of the core--
probably going to be more of
the core of Google+ stuff
rather than the Google+
platform.
So a really good place to send
this feedback, which I think
is great feedback, being a plus
page user myself, we'll
be using that little send
feedback link in the bottom
corner of the Google+
application.
And I promise it gets routed to
someone who does read it.
A lot of it's aggregated.
We don't always reply
to everything, but
someone does read it.
And that's great feedback, that
I've also heard from a
lot of other people too.
So another question, or it looks
like a few questions
from [? Abbon ?]
McDaniel.
Is there a way to do pushed
out notification to the
Google+ API?
I'm building something that
listens to Google+ developers
for I/O 2012, and notifies me
when the announcement is made.
Because he's paranoid he's
going to miss something.
Will there be a push API,
specific terms, to be produced
during that day?
This would be really cool.
There's a lot of different
push standards out there.
Like one that we like a lot at
Google is pubsubhubbub, which
is very hard to say.
JONATHAN BARRY: Push.
JENNY MURPHY: Hmm?
JONATHAN BARRY: Push is the
easier way to say it.
JENNY MURPHY: Push, yeah.
Push technologies.
We think they're really cool.
We see a lot of potential
for them.
But again, this is another
future-looking thing.
Can't make any promises.
This is something we
just don't know
the specifics about.
So there's not a lot
we can tell you.
JONATHAN BARRY: We even
have to long poll.
Watch your quota.
Do your search.
JENNY MURPHY: Exactly.
So for now you can just keep
doing-- using a technique
similar to what I showed you
on the comments API--
you can keep pulling the API and
examining the new content
for each one of those polls.
Cool.
So now that I've hammered
through a bunch of questions,
anyone in the local hangouts
have anything?
FRASER CAIN: I think that people
are now asking their
questions on the new
stream page.
You might want to check
that as well.
JENNY MURPHY: Good point.
FRASER CAIN: Looks like there's
about eight comments
over there.
JENNY MURPHY: So in the
meantime, Ed asked a question
on the previous post, since
now we've forked it.
And he asked, how long
is the wait for
increased quota limit?
So we're actually doing a lot
of things to try to improve
our response time for
quota requests.
And we're working on a
process right now.
We're making it faster
and faster.
But the real answer is that
it kind of depends.
It depends on how much quota
you're asking for, and if
you've kind of met all
of our instructions.
If you want to get a response
as quickly as possible, make
sure that you follow the
instructions we have up there,
including linking to
your application.
And following our terms
of service, like
having a privacy policy.
If you do those things,
we'll be able to
respond much faster.
JONATHAN BARRY: And just to make
sure that everybody else
knows that you can actually
submit a request for
additional quota through
the developer console.
And that goes to our team, and
we review all the things that
Jenny mentioned.
And it is on a case-by-case
basis.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah.
So it's hard to say exactly
how long it takes.
ABRAHAM WILLIAMS: Just so
people have examples.
The last time I did it, I got
a response within 24 hours.
So it's generally, in my
experience, been very fast.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, but it's
because you give us very
detailed quota requests.
It helps a lot.
So I'd probably err on the side
of telling us too much
more than too little.
Saves us research time.
So I'm looking at the other
thread now that
Fraser pointed me to.
See if there's any
questions there.
So there's the same questions in
there a few times, which is
when will hangouts on air
be open to more people?
When will everyone who's
watching be able to create
their own hangouts on air.
And this is a pretty
experimental technology.
We're opening it up to a very
small number of people.
In fact, I've personally only
gotten access really recently,
and I'm a Googler in developer
relations.
So we're being really cautious
with expanding it.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Was the crash
earlier an indication on
why it's still experimental?
JENNY MURPHY: Yes.
It was more an err of the
driver than the vehicle.
I actually hit the wrong button
and killed the hangout.
But that's the kind of things
we're trying to improve before
we open it up to a
wider audience.
Because we want to make sure
that everyone who uses this
has as good an experience
as they can.
FRASER CAIN: But there's got
to be some legal issues and
copyright issues as
well to make it
available to a wider audience.
It's a--
JONATHAN BARRY: So for people
who are actually in the
hangout, you must have saw
a friendly legal screen.
And all participants that are on
on-air hangout have to read
and confirm.
There are a bunch of legal
things in the US, and
exponentially more
around the world.
So like Martin, if he does
something that's OK in the US,
that might not be OK in
Germany, for example.
Especially around
the media laws.
MARTIN: There are a lot
of things, yeah.
FRASER CAIN: You've got to have
some very brave lawyers,
because with the sort of
potential for shenanigans with
this technology, I'm
really impressed.
They've got to just be
very brave lawyers.
JONATHAN BARRY: I think we have
frightened lawyers, and
many of them.
But we have a very compelling
community of people.
So we're pushing them hard.
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
So I see one more question.
I guess I'll field
one or two more.
Austin asks is there going to
be a centralized hangouts
portal where all the hangout
related stuff is
going to reside in?
So I'm assuming you're talking
about active hangouts that you
can go for discovery.
Discovery's definitely something
we care about.
As you can see in the Google+
interface, we're constantly
kind of adding new things to the
side column that make it
easier for you to find hangouts
that are running currently.
And we're trying to improve
discoverability within the
application itself.
As for what we do in the future,
not really sure.
That's something I can't,
again, can't talk about.
As you can see we're
making little
improvements here and there.
FRASER CAIN: Can I
ask a question
based on that comment?
Is the lack of discoverability
or the ramp of discoverability
sort of also trying to work in
the performance of the service
able to handle growing
amounts of hangouts?
Like you don't want to open
up the floodgates too far?
Like if you could have them
perfectly discoverable, would
that make you happy today, or
would you rather sort of
increase the volume?
I don't know if I'm making
any sense there.
JONATHAN BARRY: I don't know
whether I'd be able to answer
that question, because that's
more about strategy and user
experience.
But what I will tell you is most
of the features you're
seeing in Google+ have
been iterative.
And that's because everything
we add is deliberate, small
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And that's why we get this
massive flood of feedback from
all the passionate users.
And then we take our own
strategy around how we want
the product to go, and the
usability studies, and
brilliant designers to
come up with the
smallest little button.
FRASER CAIN: Well yeah, I'm just
wondering whether it was
more an issue of capacity and
bandwidth, because I'm sure
providing free video streaming
to hundreds of thousands of
people simultaneously is
taxing on servers.
JONATHAN BARRY: It is taxing.
Fortunately, we've been
investing in the technology
for many, many years.
The original Google Talk
plug-in for one-to-one
communication, YouTube
infrastructure, all that stuff.
But yes, it is a constant
challenge for anybody.
JENNY MURPHY: We're also very
concerned with making sure
that the quality of experience
people have in hangouts
remains very high.
Because what we've discovered
from feedback is that people
are having a really good time
in hangouts, and they're
having an experience that's
different than they've had in
other video chats before.
And we want to make sure
that we keep that
experience top notch.
And we think that the current
social model plays
a big part in that.
Cool.
So we're about out of time,
so I guess it's about
time to wrap up.
So does anyone have any closing
thoughts before we
call it a day?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I know you
can't comment on future plans,
but what are your future plans
on how you're going to be
running your weekly
office sessions?
JENNY MURPHY: Weekly
office sessions.
It seems like a lot of people--
we got a lot of
feedback from the chats
during this.
Probably be doing some
smaller assignments.
I'll probably be bugging a lot
of you guys, and a lot of
other people in the community
afterwards to see how to
improve it as much as we can.
We'll definitely change
the way we live
coding, if we do it again.
JONATHAN BARRY: We
will do it again.
JENNY MURPHY: We will
do it again.
We will figure out how to do
it-- just very short lines.
And we'll see.
This is a little bit of an
experiment, and each week is
one step in that experiment.
JONATHAN BARRY: And just the
general architecture is we're
going to be topic-focused.
Obviously, opening it up for
questions, both in the stream
and the participants.
But we really actually want
to educate in each one.
So today was the
comment widget.
We already have a request for
doing something in Python.
We have a bunch of hangout stuff
that we want to build as
sample apps.
And as new things do allow,
we're going to try to
incorporate those into the
Office Hours, not just hey, we
released something.
Go read the docs.
Actually try to show you how
to use it when it's fresh.
JENNY MURPHY: Although, when
we do release things, we'll
definitely be talking
about them.
But we want to make sure it's
interactive and educational
when we do it.
So when people come back later
to watch the videos, they're
useful to them and they can do
something with everything we
talk about.
FRASER CAIN: It might be cool
as well to have some of the
people actually demonstrate
some of the things that
they've built, and how
they got things done.
So other people screen sharing
as well would be pretty cool.
JENNY MURPHY: We would
love that.
So anyone out there in the world
who's building something
cool, come and show it to us.
I'm happy to hangout and even
in one-on-ones just to see
whatever they're building.
And yes, we would love to hear
from people in the developer
community about what they're
building, and we'd love to
help you show it off in
our Office Hours.
JONATHAN BARRY: We may
even do that--
why don't we do that
next week?
JENNY MURPHY: If we have someone
who has something to
show that's pretty cool, we'll
definitely bring it up some
time in the next few weeks.
JONATHAN BARRY: Perfect.
Well guys, I want to thank
everybody who joined us in the
hangout, everybody who watched
the on-air, and all the
commentaries in the stream.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah.
Thanks so much for bearing with
us, especially as the
hangout forked into a
second copy when I
hit the wrong button.
But thanks a lot, and I'll see
you guys all next week.
Goodbye.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Thanks.
Bye.
MARTIN: Bye.